Joe Biden is back to bribing voters he
just canceled another $9 billion in
student loan debt this kind of relief is
lifechanging for individuals and their
families but it's good for our economy
as a whole as well by freeing millions
of Americans from the crushing burden of
student debt it means they can go and
get their lives in order they can think
about buying a house they can start a
business they can be starting a family
this matters it matters with their daily
lives but Biden can only go so far to
bail them out Millions will have to
start paying back their federal student
loans this month after a three-year
pause the liberal media is crying over
Wealthy College grads who will be forced
to dip into their fun budget and cut
back on things like travel concerts
restaurant dining and spa days other
articles framing it as a terrifying
tradeoff with consequences for the
economy all right right Jesse I'll start
with you if Biden actually cared about
this student loan crisis and not just
the Gen Z Millennial vote he could stop
he could start by incentivizing uh
colleges and getting them to uh lower
the cost of tuition wouldn't you love to
see Biden have a college Summit with
these stupid College presidents who are
ripping off this country and just get
them in a room and just grab them all by
their necks and say
stop destroying the American dream
because you're coming out of college
with 200 Grand in debt you can't buy a
house rates are at 8% and now he's
trying to pay them off so they vote for
them how Reckless is the Press imagine a
20-year-old at a college they're going
on vacation they're going to a spa
they're going to brunch if my father
found out that I was putting Spas
brunches vacations on a credit card and
I didn't even have a family or a house
or a real career at that point he would
kick my butt I put five grand on my
father's credit card one summer and he
almost made me go to military school I
had to work my tail off the whole rest
of the summer $100 a day just to pay it
off and why don't we do that in this
country anymore it does five grand for I
can't tell you
that Martha you you know you really
can't cancel a student debt all you do
is transfer the burden to another
taxpayer yeah that's right and that's
that's why the Supreme Court that's one
of the reasons that the Supreme Court
decided that he didn't have the ability
to cancel the student debt because it
really is an issue of congressional
purse strings essentially but I'm
focused on the fact that he said you
know he wants people to be able to buy a
house as Jesse just said interest rates
are at 8% uh wants them to start a
business very difficult to start a
business these days I mean there are
ways to and start a family there are
ways to incentivize people through tax
breaks through regulation cuts that help
people have the ability to start a
business we have a very divided wealth
system in this country right now and it
has made people feel that they cannot
get ahead right and part of the problem
is this student loan burden what what
they need to do is give up these other
things right and pay the debt down as so
many people did and we need to make
wiser choices we need to encourage each
other to make wiser choices and you know
I mean in inflation has caused all of
this so this all could have been
prevented if we didn't keep throwing
money at all of these problems and
expect a different outcome Hunter
doesn't even own a home and he's
50 should we talk about Hunter now Jesse
think about it okay what is isn't
somebody else living at the White House
too the one who just got married
Hunter's daughter exactly yeah are we
paying for that too yes okay all right
Harold back to you um isn't he giving
people false hope you know he keeps
going through this you're not going to
have to pay it I'm going to take care of
you and then you know the Supreme Court
says no and now he's like he's got this
false hope he's creating
again so he might be u n n billion
dollars of student loan that I I think
you're right you got to put the presence
in the room and say the real challenge
is how do we not keep doing this going
forward number one number two we have 8
million jobs in the country that require
uh require High skills that require some
higher ed degree I've said on the show I
don't mind prioritizing where we have
needs in our economy
Engineers like electricians and plumbers
where we need more truck drivers and
nurses and teachers and family
physicians if we want to provide relief
for that we should number three we have
a $ 36 trillion doll debt in the country
uh that is placing not only pressure on
every household when you divide what
each of us may owe but it's also putting
upward pressure on interest rates
because eventually people are trying to
understand can we pay down this debt
this is this is also impacting the stock
market and everything that's happening
day in and day out I look forward when
we have leaders on both sides of the
aisle again that remind me of JFK when
he he made that powerful statement to
every American rich or poor black white
Democrat Republican Southern West Coast
wherever you may live ask not what your
country can do for you ask and said what
you can do for your country we're not
doing enough of that in politics today
this notion that we're going to do this
so kids can have more money to my dad
would have done the same thing to me and
so would my mom and I'm going to do the
same things to my kids I hope they're
listening tonight we have to teach
people to be responsible and challenge
them reward them but challenge them and
we don't do enough of that in politics
or everyday life and unfortunately this
is another example of what we should not
be doing uh to help advance and make our
country stronger Greg don't these young
people need to learn to live within
their means I don't know I mean no
wonder people uh think it's okay to loot
right I mean he just sanctioned looting
for his overeducated underwork voting
base the art history major who works on
viral videos for B light uh this is not
cancellation this is pure theft that's
all it is right and you got to ask like
why not steal if this is theft why not
steal from uh the colleges with their
billions in endowments why not steal
from the banks why are you putting it on
the taxpayer it's because one reason
they understand that the taxpayer the
people watching the show are powerless
against this assault right you aren't a
big institution with a building full of
lawyers who can fight this so can steal
from the truck driver right to
supplement the uh gender studies
graduate because the truck driver has no
way to fight back you know why steal
from us because you can you can't you
can't rob a bank or a college but you
can rob our viewers that's the sickest
part we are being robbed by the
president it's unconstitutional it's not
right it's pretty much evil so
president's evil yes okay coming up
Britain's prime minister is slamming
transgender ideology and making American
leaders look like total idiots hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else